okay it's not really a series for you I
mean it would be nice to pretend that we
have enough energy to to create anything
as dangers of the black hole pick a
knee-jerk but the energy way do you
never had a moment to consider no
there's actually an argument which
probably isn't so simple for people
understand but the so we we produce a
certain amount of energy we know exactly
what that energy is but we have high
energy particles coming from outer space
at hitter at all the time and their way
higher in energy so if a certain energy
range could produce a black hole then
these particles from outer space would
have produced tons of them in there and
what I've eaten s already so we'd all be
dead already it sets up I know it sounds
like a it's not that easy you know it
doesn't you know you have to think about
the difference between two things
colliding a car crash in which you hit
it head-on versus one where once at rest
but the energies from matters from
things coming from space would have
absolutely destroyed her just no
question about so we're not anywhere
close we're safe from that point it'd be
different I mean there was an accident
in which the thing blew up in the fall
of 2008 and it took a year and a half to
fix it this was a technical problem in
that a magnet developed a short and then
some helium leaked and it was a violent
explosion in the tunnel and so so
accidents happen even in these big
projects but not at the level of beating
her they're funny things to worry about
like nuclear weapons but this is not not
one